The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation, or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
GANG CHEN: OK, hope you
all had a good weekend.
And if you recall,
last time, we were
talking about the
Fermi-Dirac distribution,
Bose-Einstein distribution.
And as I say, this is the
average number of particles
in one quantum state.
So a certain energy, and
with a certain temperature,
and with certain
chemical potential.
And we state that for
phonons and photons,
thermal equilibrium, the
camera potential mu equals 0.
However, I caution you, if you
do in light-emitting devices,
or if you do solar
cells, the [INAUDIBLE]
potential of photons, the
emitted photons, is not 0.
And that's because in this
case, the photon is interacting
with the electrons
holes, and you have,
let's say, electron holes
that have not the equilibrium,
and that's in this
case, you actually
have a mu not equaling 0.
And that's why the light emitted
from a light-emitting diode
or laser can be much higher
than the black body radiation
intensity.
And from there, once we
have this average number
of particles, we will discuss
the applications essentially
what we have discussed now
is the quantum mechanics
tells me, what's the energy
of any matter I give you?
A crystal, what's the
electron energy levels?
What's the phono energy
level, so a molecule or atom?
In principle, we can solve
this for the quantum mechanical
allowable ground state energy.
There's no temperature there.
And then, we add it to each
quantum state, the distribution
function, f, that's how many--
so this is the energy
of a quantum state,
this is how many particles we
have at that quantum state.
And then, we discuss
the density of states,
that's per near
that energy level,
how many of those
quantum states?
So we're doing accounting.
And by this time, what
I'm hoping is using--
so we show the black
body radiation,
in that case is a [INAUDIBLE].
And the Bose-Einstein
distribution density
of the state of photons.
And you can easily say
the black-body radiation
are based on this expression.
If you need a chair there,
other chairs are in the front.
And then if you take--
so this gives the
energy density, right?
And if you take a temperature
derivative of that energy
density, you get
the specific heat.
Although for photons we seldom
talk about specific heat,
and that's why for photons
the lattice we can measure,
so we use the specific heat.
And the low temperature
you get T-cubic power.
And that's very similar to
what is black-body radiation
normal T-force power.
That's the energy and the
temperature derivative
to give you T-cubic power.
So by the end of
the last lecture,
I said I'm going to tell you I
could just stop here and move
to the next chapter.
But I'm going to use
half of today's lecture
to tell you the statistical
foundation because there
is some very useful language.
I'm not going to
test you, as I said.
But I thought it was
really beautiful.
So it's good that
you have some-- you
know the terminologies here.
So in statistics what
do we want if I have,
for example, a system where
the equilibrium surrounding,
I want to measure
its energy, or I want
to measure its temperature.
So what I have is
a time average.
I do a certain
amount of measurement
over a certain period of
time because instantaneously
those quantities
are fluctuating.
So one way to find a
quality that we report
is the time average.
But in statistical
mechanics the framework
is developed most along
the ensemble average.
There is a time average.
For example, if you do
molecular dynamics simulation,
you actually solve
the equation of motion
and you get the
trajectory of the atoms,
and you see how to
do the averaging.
And the ensemble
average is based on not
considering time history--
so if I have a system, there
are many quantum mechanics
that say, OK, I can go
to solve in principle--
Schrodinger
equation-- I find all
quantum states of the system.
So I have quantum state one
and all those quantum states.
And this omega is
typically much, much larger
than the number of
particles you have.
In fact, we'll see soon even
one atom, the quantum state--
say the allowable quantum state
in this room for one molecule--
will be much, much larger
than the total number
of molecules in this room.
So this is a huge number, omega.
And the ensemble
average is actually
looking at each of these quantum
states, the time evolution.
But right now let's
not think about time.
Each quantum state,
what's the probability?
So if you do a
statistic averaging,
what's the probability for
observing quantum state I?
Right?
And in that quantum state,
what's this quantity Xi?
For example, what's the
energy of that quantum state?
What's the momentum
of that quantum state?
Microscopic, right?
Where we're targeting.
And now the probability--
now for that, say one side of
the system in my ensemble--
this is a many state
form of ensemble, right?
So if I know the probability
of observing that quantum
state in the ensemble,
then now the value
that I'm interested in that
specific ensemble, then
my average--
the ensemble average--
is then Xi Pi and sum
over all the quantum states.
So this is the concept
of ensemble average.
And that's in statistics
we do most of the time.
We don't actually try to
solve the time history,
because time
history, like I said,
is only a tool that was
developed so a computer could
become very powerful.
You saw, for example, in
molecular dynamics, right?
So there is a very
fundamental assumption
when these two different
ways of averaging
are equal to each other.
A system, when the time average
equals the ensemble average,
that's called ergodic.
So ergodic system is
when the time average
equals the ensemble average.
And most systems are ergodic.
It turns out that studying
long ergodic systems
is actually an active branch
for strategic physics.
So ergodic system is
one that after some time
it tends to equilibrium.
The samples of all the states.
But there are
interesting examples
of long ergodic systems.
I can't help but
give you one example.
And this example is
a famous problem.
The FPU problem.
It's a Fermi-Pasta-Ulam.
So it turns out in the 1950s,
when the computer was just
becoming available,
Fermi-Pasta-Ulam, they
published a report.
It was another UN paper.
And what they reported
is that they simulated
a one dimensional atomic
chain and the sprint
is not a harmonic.
Right?
Before when we
started [INAUDIBLE],,
we started harmonic.
Kx.
F equals Kx.
And they added a
higher order term.
A long linear term.
And what that long linear term--
this is what they, later
on, would discuss more--
is the cause for scattering.
If I have a perfect
crystal, or that spring,
just to say we have
the full picture there,
you have infinite
thermal conductivity
because the waves are not
interacting with each other.
So if I have a crystal, I
create a disturbance here.
They do not interact.
They propagate infinitely.
So a perfect crystal with
a perfect harmonic spring
has infinite thermal
conductivity.
And most material has a
finite thermal conductivity
because those springs
are long, have
a higher order of
terms that start
to interact in different modes.
That's a scattering.
That's what we're going
to talk about more.
So the reason they started
long harmonic spring
is to look at the scattering
in this atomic chain.
But what they found
is very interesting.
And they found that if
they put a one mode--
put the energy into one mode--
after some time the energy of
this mode gave to other modes.
But after a long
time of simulating--
so if it's a normal
system, we're
going to approach equilibrium.
So every mode gathers
some energy, right?
You put the energy in
one mode, and eventually
equal partition and every
mode gets some energy.
But what they found is
that after some time,
all the energy came
back to this mode.
OK?
So what that implies is that
this system is not ergodic.
It doesn't approach
the equilibrium.
And so from that
what they imply--
I'm very interested in
this because they also
imply this atomic chain has an
infinite thermal conductivity.
Energy never dissipates.
And that was actually
my motivation
when I got a call from
a friend at Intel.
He said, we're looking at the
solution for heat spreading.
Thermal management.
And I look, and I say, OK.
He said the scanning
noise is going to--
Moore's law is going
to come to an end.
We're going to make, rather
than just shrink the gap,
but we're going to
make more products.
So I look at my
cell phone, right?
Or if you look at your
iPad, it's all metal here.
And some of the old
cell phones are plastic.
AUDIENCE: That's glass.
GANG CHEN: Huh?
GANG CHEN: Not glass.
They're metals.
This is pretty heavy.
Well it's actually-- so the iPad
has aluminum in the backing.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, but
that backing is glass.
GANG CHEN: These are all glass?
AUDIENCE: The backing is glass.
GANG CHEN: Yeah, but there
should be a metal here, right?
[LAUGHTER]
But basically, metal is
used to spread out heat.
You say why your
iPad the backside,
there's aluminum to
spread out the heat.
So I say, can I turn polymer
into a good heat conductor?
So I said, oh, I
remember FPU problem.
Maybe a polymer chain is
an infinite heat conductor.
So that's how we actually
started some polymer work,
and we were able
to turn polymer--
at least made it as
good as most metals.
We achieved a 300
times improvement
in the molecular
chain direction.
That's just a fiber.
A single molecule
we don't know yet.
The theory-- the calculations
may even be much higher.
Maybe even divergent.
We have not been
able to measure it.
So think about the fundamental
aspects that sometimes give you
motivation in which directions
you want to look at.
But that's just-- there
are not many systems that
are long ergodic.
Most systems are ergodic, so we
can have the ensemble average
equals time average.
With this I'm going to say
there are different ensembles.
OK?
And I'm going to discuss
three major ensembles.
You can construct
your own ensemble.
So it depends on the macroscopic
constraint to the total system.
There are three types.
One is, I give you a system,
and that's a closed system.
And I fix the total number
of particles, the volume,
and the energy.
So this ensemble has a
fixed amount of energy,
a fixed amount of numbers
of particles, and volume.
And that's an isolated system.
Energy is a constant,
and it doesn't
interact with the surrounding.
Volume is constant.
Number of particles is constant.
That's an isolated system.
So it turns out that
the probability--
So what I'm looking
at is, what's
the probability of
observing a quantum
state of this macroscopic system
which has many quantum states?
So this is one
type of constraint.
And the next type
of constraint, is
I don't do an isolated system.
Rather than the
energy as a constant,
I have the temperature
as a constant.
So I have N, V, T.
And in this case,
temperature is constant so
the energy can fluctuate,
and it can interact with
the surrounding environment.
Let's say the environment is
at a constant temperature.
And the third is a
system that I don't need
to fix the number of particles.
It can have mass exchange,
particle exchange,
with it's surroundings.
So if the particles
are in exchange--
either equilibrium
when my system is--
the thermal equilibrium,
temperature is equal.
When a system has mass
equilibrium, the particle
equilibrium, the chemical
potential is equal.
So I deal with the
system the [INAUDIBLE]
potential of volume,
temperature is fixed.
The number of particles
are not fixed.
So now for each of these,
I can take a system
and I make an ensemble.
And in this case I make an
ensemble of quantum state I.
I for quantum state, that has
a fixed number, N, V, U. What's
the probability of observing
this quantum state?
That's the P. That's
what I want to find out.
And similarly, for this one,
again I is quantum state.
What's the probability?
But in this case, I have N,
I have V, I have T. Right?
I do not have fixed energy.
And this system may have
a specific energy Ei,
rather than a given energy.
What's the probability of
observing this quantum state--
specific quantum state--
in the whole ensemble?
I have many, many
of such states.
And the same is for this.
In this case, the I quantum
state can have Ei, Ni.
The particle is also not fixed.
And I have mu, V, T. So
those are the questions
we want to answer.
The probability of Pi.
And here it's Ei.
And the rest N, V, T. And
here is P, Ei, and Ni.
And the rest of the
fixed quantity, mu, N, T.
So we want to find out
what's the probability.
And we have specific names for
the three different constraints
in the ensemble form.
Here is a microcanonical.
And here is canonical.
And here is grand canonical.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
GANG CHEN: What's the
name you want again?
AUDIENCE: I'm just guessing
macro, but grand is better.
GANG CHEN: OK.
Grand canonical.
So it's three different
canonical ensembles.
OK.
And the starting point
is the microcanonical.
And once you settle
on that microcanonical
you can derive all the
distribution probability
for all other canonical systems.
So the microcanonical ensemble--
So if I have a total of omega
systems in this ensemble,
microcanonical.
Right?
And the probability
for microcanonical--
there's no proof,
it's a principle--
is that for such a system
everybody has equal right.
So equal probability.
So in this case it's
equal probability
because I have a total
of omega quantum state.
Each quantum state
is 1 over omega.
So this is an equal
probability assumption.
And based on this
it was Boltzmann
who said for such a system--
The Boltzmann
principal collected
the number of
ensembles in the system
is a direct measure of the
entropy of this system.
So the Boltzmann
principal says the entropy
of such a system,
which is a function
of the macroscopic
constraint N, V, U--
so entropy is a function of N,
V, U, which is Kb log omega.
That's the Boltzmann principle.
Boltzmann was very depressed.
He was a great scientist and
didn't get the recognition.
He actually jumped in to a lake.
And so if you have a
chance to go to Vienna,
his tombstone is the
S equals Kb log omega.
So what they say
here, is the entropy--
with this one you have to also
take a lot of probability.
And by taking a
logarithm, you actually
make the entropy
additive quantity.
If you have two subsystems,
the total entropy of the system
is the entropy--
the sum of the entropy
of each system.
Because if you have two
systems, each one has the omega,
the total combination of the
state is omega 1 times omega 2.
So that makes the log
give you the summation.
So the fact that I
have functioning S,
is a functional of N,V, U, this
is called the thermodynamic
function.
Thermodynamic potential.
So it turns out for a
microcanonical ensemble,
the thermodynamic
potential is the entropy.
If you know entropy as
a function of N, V, U,
you know everything
about this system.
But if you know this as a
function of other variables,
like mu, or temperature, you do
not have that right potential.
You do not have all
the information.
So why is that?
So if I say I know
the S of the system,
I can find all other quantities
because if I look at this S
is a function of N, V, U--
So I have ds, du.
And I can keep my N,
my weight, constant.
du, if I write it
into partial, ds, dv,
and I write U and N
constant, dv plus ds dn,
and I have U,
weight constant, dN.
This is just
partial derivatives.
And if you go to
think about what
you write in typical
thermodynamics,
you write U equals
Tds minus a Pdv.
So with that I can say,
really, what I have, ds and du,
is 1 over T du.
So if I know this function,
I know the temperature.
And a ds dv is
really P over T dv.
So now the pressure and--
say ds, dn is the chemical
potential over T dn.
And using this
you could write it
into your more familiar form.
This is a du equals a Tds,
minus a pdv, and plus mu dn.
Right, this is the form that
you're more familiar with.
So what I miss--
if I know this function, I
can find mu, I can find P,
I can find T of this system.
So I know everything
about this system.
But typically we do not do
microcanonical ensembles.
Microcanonical ensembles
are harder to work with.
And many times we like
to work with a system
at a constant temperature.
Or if you recall when
we deal with electrons,
we say, OK, I take one
system, and there could
be electrons in, electrons out.
So that's how it's right, the
Fermi-Dirac, Bose-Einstein
distributions.
So that's actually the result
of grand canonical ensemble.
So let's move on
to say, if I have
here a microcanonical
ensemble, what
would be the canonical
ensemble probability?
Again I want to find what's
the probability of a quantum
system, a quantum state,
that has energy Ei.
But unlike
microcanonical ensemble
in which every system
has equal rights,
this one is no
longer equal right.
And if we want to use what we
just learned on microcanonical
to derive an expression
for the probability
in this canonical
ensemble, what you do
is you enclose the environment.
Because this system
is not isolated.
But if I enclose
the environment--
here is the environment.
And all together this
is a closed system.
And I have one quantum
state of the system itself.
I have the energy, Ei.
The environment has
many, many other states.
So the environment that will
have omega i quantum state.
So I have to quantize
my environment
because each
combination gives me
a system in the
microcanonical ensemble.
So if this omega t is the total
quantum state of a combined--
total of a combined system
plus environment together--
System plus environment
together, that gives me
the total number of states.
And then omega i is when
the system is at one quantum
state, the i's quantum state
with the energy Ei, what's
a number of states
of the environment?
So if this is omega t,
and the combined is Ut--
that's the total energy--
and the entropy of the combined
system and environment is St.
And in this case, the
energy, because I have--
the combined the
system plus environment
is my isolated system.
So when the system itself
at the Ei, the energy
of the environment Ut minus Ei.
They add together and gave
me constant Ut, right?
So Ut minus Ei.
That's the energy
of the environment.
So my probability--
This is the quantum
states of environment.
So my probability of
counting the system, my Ei,
a certain temperature,
now of course,
I can write as a volume.
Say, Lambert density.
My microscopic constraint is 1.
That's the one quantum
state of the system.
How many states this
will total comp--
how much did the environment
that also has the--
say, when this system
is at the energy, Ei.
And divide that by omega t.
That's total.
So now I need to do
a little bit of math
using the fact that it's
a microcanoncial ensemble
to derive this probability.
So let me say here is omega i.
I have this energy, but my real
average energy of the system
is U. Ei is just as
specific quantum state.
So what's the energy
of that state, right?
So the average energy--
because in this case, the
average energy can fluctuate.
Because of the
constant temperature,
energy can fluctuate.
So I can write this Ut minus Ei,
in terms of Ut minus U, which
is the average
energy of the system,
plus U minus Ei,
which is a deviation.
U minus Ei is a deviation
from the equilibrium,
the average energy.
So that's just a function
I'm rewriting in variables.
And divided that by omega t.
I could write--
now I can go back
to use the Boltzmann principle.
Omega and the S relation.
So I have omega for the
environment at this energy.
And omega for the total.
So I can write it in terms of
S. So I have, if you look at it,
it's an inversion.
So it's exponential s when
the system, the energy
is Ut minus U, plus U minus Ei.
This is just a variable
inside divide by kb.
And I have a log already.
I have an exponential already.
You will see the
Boltzmann factor.
And here I have e s of the
total of the system, Ut and kb.
So I'm using the result to
determine S and log of omega.
And here I'm going to expand--
this S I'm going to expand.
The reason I write it into this
is that I'm going to expand--
this is the equilibrium,
the average of the system.
This is the average
of the environment.
Ut minus U. And this is a
deviation from that average.
So I can write this in
terms of E equals S,
equals S Ut, team minus U,
plus ds, du, and U minus Ei.
That's a Taylor expansion.
Right?
ds, du, given the microcanonical
ensemble, ds, du is 1 over T.
So now if you go one more
step, this is 1 over T.
Here we have 1
over T, U minus Ei.
So what I have then
is P, Ei, real the
T. I don't need to carry
anyway, which is fixed.
It doesn't change.
So it's exponential S, Ut minus
U. And plus U minus Ei over T.
And I should have kb, and
here I should also have kb,
divide by exponential S, Ut.
So the entropy-- the
average entropy here
of the total system
minus the system.
So this is really the
entropy of the environment.
The entropy of the environment,
this is the total entropy.
So S, Ut is the S,
Ut minus U. That's
the entropy of the environment.
S, U, that's the
entropy of the system.
The additive
property of entropy.
So with that, this S,
U cancels this one.
And what I have is now
exponential U minus ST over kb.
That's one.
Oh, kbT.
And the other is the
exponential minus Ei over kbT.
This I combine by using
the relation here.
So this is the probability
of a canonical system,
a canonical ensemble.
When one quantum
state has energy, Ei,
and the system is a temperature
T, what's the probability?
And before, U is the
system's average energy,
S is the system's average
entropy, and temperature.
So this one is an independent
of each quantum state.
Here is the quantity
for each quantum state.
And I can write this as
exponential minus Ei,
kbT over Z. And that's Z--
1 over Z is really
this factor here.
What is U minus S, T?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
GANG CHEN: Yeah, that's what
they come for, free energy.
F. F equals U minus S, T. So
my thermodynamic potential
for a canonical
system is actually
F. F is U minus S, T. If I
know F as a function of T,
then wait.
I need to know that function.
F is a function of
N, V, T, then I know
everything about this system.
So let's do a few more steps.
Here is my probability.
Of course, I can find
out what's the relation
between Z and the Ei?
Because my probability
adds up P, Eim and t,
that has to equal the sum
of all quantum states.
It must be what?
Normalization.
And from here, I can
say my Z is really
sum over e minus Ei, kbT.
And because F equals U minus T,
S, now I have Z. I have this.
And I can find--
I can also write the
[INAUDIBLE] free energy here.
So based on the
relationship I have here,
the thermodynamic potential
for a canonical system,
which is N, V, T, and if I this
function, which is log, kbT,
log Z--
this is the one I write.
Rewrite this one.
And I have F equals
kbT log Z. And if I
know this free-form free energy,
as a functional of N, V, T,
I should know everything
about this system.
So you can say now the beauty
is this ensemble approach
is, once we start the
microcanonical ensemble
as a basic assumption
of equal probability,
you can derive probability
for all other ensembles.
And if you happen to
do molecular dynamics
simulation, and you
say that at the end
there is actually something--
most people don't discuss this--
is that when you
simulate the system,
you typically simulate the
microcanonical ensemble.
You simulate a system
with a fixed number
of particles and total energy.
And in fact you
spend a lot of time
trying to maintain
your energy constant.
Otherwise your
simulation blows up.
It's not stable.
But when you do analysis,
you actually go--
this is, as I mentioned
before, you have
to go to chapter 10 of my book.
And you actually use the
canonical example result.
And Boltzmann statistics.
This is the Boltzmann
factor here.
We mentioned it before.
So there is an inherent
inconsistency in this approach.
And people did discuss
the ways to treat it.
In fact, one way,
for example, is
to add a thermostat to the
molecular dynamics simulation.
And there are different
ways to add a thermostat
so you can actually add an
additional equation of motion
to simulate the environment,
so that, as a whole,
you can still have
self-consistency.
So there are different
thermostat constants.
The temperature
thermostat, they're
are even constant
pressure thermostats--
but if you go to
check all this paper,
it actually invariably
comes to those basic
how you can go from
one ensemble result
to another ensemble result.
So I spent a lot
of time in talking
going from microcanonical
to canonical, right?
The nest one here
is a closed system
but a constant temperature.
So energy exchange
with the environment.
Now if you have an open system
and a constant temperature,
there is both energy
and particle exchange
with the environment.
And you do the same thing.
So you will find that
the last probability--
I'm not going to derive it now.
The grand canonical, and the
probability of a quantum system
has energy Ei.
Has Ni particles.
It's exponential minus
Ei, minus mu, Ni, kbT.
That's why we used that before.
And divide that by another
partition function.
This one, this Z is called
a partition function.
The same Z there is
partition function.
And say the factor here,
this is what at the start
I said was a Gibbs factor.
That's how we derived
Fermi-Dirac and Einstein
distribution.
We start with this
probability, and then we
say normalization that will
give me the partition function
there.
The normalization factor,
I used to use the symbol A.
But here it's symbol Z.
And the same thing here.
So this is a Boltzmann
factor for canonical.
That's the Gibbs factor
for grand canonical,
for an open system.
So this is essentially--
what did I say?
It's a statistical
foundation, and
a beautiful
mathematical treatment,
once you start with
microcanonical.
And it's pretty--
it's a deep concept.
So I'm not asking you to--
I said I'm not
going to test you,
but I want you to
know the terminology.
Now let's look at a few
examples of how we use this.
Let's apply this
to a few problems.
And I discussed the electrons.
I discussed [INAUDIBLE],,
Fermi-Dirac, Bose-Einstein.
And now let's go
back to gas molecule.
Right, if you
recall in chapter 1,
we discussed the
Maxwell distribution.
Velocity.
We said, OK, the energy of
a molecule is one half m,
Vx squared, plus Vy
squared, plus Vz squared.
But you could also do quantum
particle in box solution.
We saw this.
When you have a
particle in your box,
and that is h bar squared 2m,
Kx squared, plus Ky squared,
plus Kz squared.
You can do either
quantum or classical.
I'm going to actually use
the quantum notation here.
This is essentially-- the
h, k, gives you momentum.
P squared to m.
That's the quantum here.
And of course,
given the energy, I
can go to look at
this as a system
at a constant temperature.
So I can use the canonical
example and the partition
function for one particle.
For one particle it's Z1,
and that will be summing up
all possible Kx, Ky, Kz.
Kx, Ky, Kz.
And so it sums up
all energy levels
as what we were showing in the--
where did it [INAUDIBLE].
Right, Z is the sum of
all energy quantum states.
So sum of all quantum states.
And the exponential Ei, which is
a function of Kx, Ky, Kz, kbT.
So this is my
partition function Z.
And if I want to know
what's the average energy--
I have my average energy, E
is just, again, a summation.
I can write a Kx, Ky, Kz, rather
than three summation symbols.
And this is the E as
this combination of--
for each state, it's how much
energy and the probability
for this quantum state.
That probability is what I
have here, Ei, kbT over Z.
So I have the
probability expression,
I have the energy expression,
I can go to find that average.
But there is a
simpler way, rather
than doing this summation.
And you can actually
prove easily,
if I take a
derivative of this Z,
you say this one is
actually equals d
log Z1, dy, where y equals kbT.
That's just the
mathematical result.
And for convenience,
if I find this
I can just take the
derivative of Z1.
If you see, because if I do
a derivative, I will log--
I say this is in the
denominator, that gives me Z.
And the numerator essentially
gives me probability.
And if I take kbT as--
Oh, 1 over-- this should be.
That y should be--
No, I think actually
dy should give me--
y should be 1 over
kbT, rather than kbT.
So if you do that, you'll
get the E in the front.
That's the E in the front.
So that means I do not need
to actually do this summation.
If I just find the Z1,
my problem is solved.
And then to do Z1, I
can word the summation.
If this one doesn't
change rapidly,
I do my summation
into integration
using density of states.
If it changes rapidly,
I cannot do that.
So if it's a very-- if the
states are far apart, or a kT,
I cannot do that
integration to summation.
Its summation to integration.
So now, because these states
are closely spaced, I can do it.
So you find out Z1.
From this I can actually
do my integration.
This exponential E, kbT
over density of states,
dE, as 0 to infinite,
and this density
of states for
particles in the box,
given this dispersion
energy with vector relation,
you'll find that
there is a way for--
we did this before, so I'm
not going to re-derive it.
h squared, 2m, h
squared and 3/2.
We did it in the
context of electrons.
But they could be the
same for molecules.
So you substitute the density
upstage energy into it,
and you find out this
one equals V, the volume,
divided by lambda cubic,
where this lambda cubic is--
Or lambda itself.
Not lambda cubic.
Lambda itself.
h squared, 2pi, mkbT.
So this is your lambda.
And this lambda is called the
thermal de Broglie wavelengths.
It's the thermal de
Broglie wavelengths.
De Broglie wavelengths.
Why is it called thermal
de Broglie wavelengths?
Basically if you think
about your energy as kbT,
you go from that energy
to momentum because kbT,
1/2 kbT energy equals momentum
P squared divide by 2m.
From momentum you go
convert it into wavelengths.
That's what you will get.
So it's called thermal
de Broglie wavelengths.
So from Z, if I go into here
because y is 1 over kbT,
so you take a log, and
you take a derivative,
you find the average energy of
this equals mass d log Z, dy,
and equals 3/2 kbT.
That's the result
we found when we
did the Maxwell distribution.
We came back to the same result,
but through a different--
this is a more rigorous
statistical approach foundation
there.
And it says the average energy
of a particle is 3/2 kbT.
And recall, we commented
the equal partition, if you
have quadratic determined
energy, here is 1/2 m,
Vx squared.
Or kx squared.
That's quadratic term.
Right?
And if this energy does
not separate that far part,
at a high temperature, each
mode contributed 1/2 kbT.
That's equal partition.
So I have three modes
here, I have 3/2 kbT.
Of course, from here the
specific heat of one molecule
is du, de, dt.
So it's 3/2 kb.
Right?
Specifically the one
molecule is 3/2 kb.
And if it's one more--
one more is 3/2 kb times
Avogadro constraint.
This too gives you the
universal gas constant.
That's what you know from
thermodynamics, is that 3/2 R.
But you say, no,
that's not all 3/2,
that's only a monatomic gas.
What about diatomic gas?
Who will remember that.
What's the specific
heat of diatomic gas?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
GANG CHEN: 5, right?
5 hops R. So why is that?
OK, so let's go to--
This is only one molecule.
Let me add one more comment.
When I have dilute particles,
here I have-- before
that was one molecule.
If I have N molecules
and if my energy is, say,
the summation of all the
molecule Ei, and the kbT.
And the question is how
to do this summation.
It it's dilute
molecules, that means--
diluted means really the energy
levels of those molecules
do not affect each other.
So my individual molecule
solution is pretty much valid,
and all the molecules have
the same energy levels.
So in that case,
I will have-- this
is for each identical
quantum state.
Ei.
I have N molecules.
So I have exponential
Z1 to the n-th power.
But there is one trick
that says the molecules are
indistinguishable.
If you do a combination, if
it's indistinguishable objects,
What do you do?
The probability
of counting them?
AUDIENCE: You write
that and then--
GANG CHEN: So you'll
divide it by N factorial.
So that's if it's
indistinguishable.
But when they are, it's dilute.
Right?
So when I say dilute, I say
the molecule to not affect
each other's energy levels.
When I say dilute, one
condition I can use
is the number of
states of one molecule
in the box is much larger
than the number of particles.
The Lambert quantum
state of one molecule
is much larger than the
number of particles.
So the particles do not
influence each other.
And so the number
of states, it's
really Kx, Ky, Kz, times 1.
Each combination of Kx,
Ky, Kz gives me one state.
So I have the density of states
integrated over all energy.
And if the energy is 0,
I can say roughly it's
3, because the average
energy is 3/2 kbT.
And that gives me much
larger than the total number
of molecules.
And this actually
gives me the condition,
if you do your math again,
we have [INAUDIBLE] states
and weigh pi over 6, and 1/2
lambda cubic, much less than 1.
So that's the mathematics.
What it means, you say lambda
cubic, lambda is the de Broglie
wavelengths, right?
So V divide by N, if I move V
to the end of this side, that's
the volume of one particle.
It's much larger than the
thermal de Broglie wavelengths.
So the wave of
each atom does not
overlap with the other atoms.
So that's the particle dilution.
Dilute particles.
OK, so how I go from
here to 3/5 kbT.
And if I have the
total energy here,
we only consider
the translation.
So if I have the energy
of one particular, Ei,
here we have a translation.
Plus you can also have
rotation of the particle.
You can have the
vibration of the particle.
And the electronic.
So the total partition function
for N molecules is really
Z of the--
here we have translation,
and rotation, and vibration,
and the electronic
partition function.
Each of those to the n-th power
and divided by N factorial.
And from this, En, you go
to take the average energy--
once you find that Z--
you take the average energy
and take the temperature
derivative.
So it really depends
on, at the end--
because it's a
Boltzmann factor, Ei,
my electronic energy is
a few electron volts.
Let's think about this.
What's this [INAUDIBLE] here?
Electrons, the energy level--
this is a simple hydrogen
model.
This is minus 13.6 [INAUDIBLE].
This is a minus 13.6 divide
by 4 because it's N squared.
That's a big gap here.
So the electronic
energy normally
is not excited, because the
Ei over kbT is a huge number.
And this [INAUDIBLE].
So electrons do not go
to a higher energy level,
and they do not contribute
to specific heat
at room temperature.
Because when temperatures
change, their energy--
they're still at
the ground state.
And vibration energy
level, what do you
know about the vibration
frequency of hydrogen?
If you think about the
gas atmospheric absorption
spectrum, right?
And in the infrared,
a few microns,
you got a lot of lines, right?
Those lines are the
vibrational energy levels.
Vibration plus rotation.
Rotation is a small energy.
Vibration is actually-- this
is many rotations attached
to vibration.
So if vibration is a few
microns, that means about 0.2,
0.3, to 0.5 electron volts.
Few microns.
1 micron is 1.24 electron volts.
Right so if it's 2
micron, it's 0.6.
4 micron, 0.3 electron volts.
kT is 26 million electron volts.
26 million electron volts.
So when you have--
this is a 0.3 divided by 0.03,
that exponential is minus 10.
So normally vibration at room
temperature is not excited.
And rotation turns out
very low temperature.
Just the rotation itself.
The energy needed to
rotate the object.
And that's the
equivalent temperature--
It's about 80 Kelvin.
So at room temperature,
the rotation,
the molecule rotational
modes, all rotation modes,
are excited.
And if you think about rotation,
there's two degrees of freedom.
Right?
Theta phi.
The energy is 1/2
omega, I squared.
No.
1/2 I omega squared.
It's a quadratic.
The equity partition
says there will
be another lot 2, times 1/2 kT.
So if you go to look at
the specific heat of a gas,
it's actually not
just a stat function.
It really depends on
what the temperature
range you're dealing with is.
And specific heat of constant
volume-- specific heat.
This is the temperature.
And the translation is easily
excited motion translation.
So this is 3/2 R, universal
gas constant per Moore.
And around 80 Kelvin, the
rotations start to kick in.
So there is a transition range.
And when you go to
higher temperature,
all the rotational
energy is fully excited.
Equity partition
begins to be valid.
It's another sharp
transition there.
So here you got 5/2 Ru.
That's where you say when
you do your gas calculation,
you say this
specifically is 5/2.
And when you go to
thousands of degrees,
you add another vibration.
It's 1/2 Nv squared,
plus 1/2 Kx squared.
So two quadratic terms.
You add another 2 times 1/2 kbT.
Equal partition.
But this will require you to
go to the thousandth degree.
So for gas you can go to--
it's a diatomic gas.
Go to 7/2.
If you have three
atoms, you have
to look at more of those
different modes per molecule.
So that's the discussion
on specific heat.
And I think that
what's really for you
probably the most
useful is understanding
gas specific heat,
and the previous--
I spent most of
today's lecture really
discussing different ensembles.
I just want you to
know their treatment.
This is the statistical
foundation of ergodicity.
And the ensemble average,
and different ensembles.
From microcanonical,
to canonical,
and grand canonical ensembles.
And just briefly,
where we're going.
Now if you look at what
we have discussed so far--
I repeat this before.
What we know now is the
energy of an atom, of a solid,
and molecules.
That's ground state energy.
Quantum mechanical solution.
What are the allowable
states of the system?
And I have for each quantum
state, and the equilibrium,
I can tell what the average
number of particles,
and I can count how
many states, and use
the concept density of states.
And of course my start
point is to really sum up
all the discrete states.
But this summation many times I
can use the density of states.
And of course the
condition for that
is that the separation
of energy levels
are a lot farther
apart compared to kbT.
So between two
adjacent levels, I
can actually convert
that summation using
integration approximation.
Summations are
actually accurate.
Integration is approximation.
It's a reverse.
So typically, when
we do integration,
we do discrete summation, right?
And the other comment is
on the quantum systems.
And that summation
becomes, sometimes,
invalid because the
separation is large.
So I want to show you--
we discussed electrons before.
And I want to show a few
slides on the [INAUDIBLE],,
specific heat, and if
you have nanostructures,
what will happen.
OK, so this was actually
a student of mine.
And it took me a
while to actually
really appreciate this.
In fact, in my original concept
that was not quite right.
So it's a density
of states summation.
If you want to get a
specific heat of material,
you sum up the
density of states.
So you have a slab, a
wire, a slab, and the 3D.
In one direction the
distance is very small,
they say you can look
at your energy levels,
and they start to separate.
And as you can see,
the density of states
are for 1D, and 2D, and 3D.
It's 3D for the bimodel.
That's omega squared.
And 2D is steps.
And then 1D, spikes.
This is a-- actually for
electrons, they are similar.
Spikes for 1D, and 2D we
already say it's a staircase.
It's steps for electrons.
And for [INAUDIBLE] it's
pretty much similar,
except if you
average them out, you
follow this omega
squared contour there.
So if you add this together,
you get the specific heat.
So this was a measurement that
we did on titanium dioxide
nanotubes.
And you count circular modes and
the spacing between the layers.
And when you integrate,
you get what's
the specific heat trend for
different-- say, 3D, 2D,
1D structures.
And there was an experiment.
This was a measurement--
and for specific heat, if you
really want to say for lattice,
you want to see
quantization, in fact,
you have to go with a
very low temperature.
And as you can see, this
is most of the case.
It really is pretty good.
You go to a very low temperature
to see the divisions.
And let me see whether--
in fact there are not
really much measurements
on the electronic specific
heat quantum structures.
Let me see whether there any--
is this-- no.
So for electronic structure,
actually calculating
specific heat it is not
easy because, remember,
we say you have to calculate
the chemical potential,
because of the
Fermi-Dirac system.
And chemical potential
is calculated
by the number of particles
equal to the modes.
That's the 1.
And the spin.
So how many--
Oh, not the 1.
It's a Fermi-Dirac
distribution because this
is harmonic quantum state.
Each quantum state, how
many particles do you have?
And then combined with
the energy, both f,
contain chemical
potential and temperature.
So when this is a
discrete, it's not easy.
You have two equations
you have to solve.
And that's why it's
a little bit complex
for electronic specific
heat in quantum systems.
For bulk, it's 1 over-- say
just a specific increase with T.
OK, so what are we
going to do next?
We know how to calculate
equilibrium quantities and heat
storage, for example.
And we're next looking
into the transport process.
And then we need to find
out long equilibrium.
So if I have 0.1
and 0.2, and they're
either different temperature or
different chemical potential,
what's the mass flux?
What's the heat flux?
So I have not
discussed-- we have not
discussed this quantity.
Say it's going
from 1 to 2, what's
the probability that
the transmission?
And also, what's the velocity?
And in fact, I
have shaded away--
I'm not really
talking about what's
the speed of the
energy moving, right?
What's the speed of
light, the speed of sound.
But when we discuss the
speed of energy carrier,
you have to actually
think about the energy
packet, and the group velocity.
And so in the next
chapter, next lecture,
we're going to start
our philosophies.
We'll first discussed
the wave, when
it goes through the
interface, there's reflection.
That's how we
calculate transmission.
And then we'll discuss the wave
as a packet for group velocity.
And then we'll go translate
from the [INAUDIBLE] picture
to see eventually we neglect
the phase carrying by the way.
So that's in the
next few lectures.
We'll focus on the waves.
And that's pretty much it.
So far, we've been
really building
a foundation based on waves.
So go from waves, you
mentioned the forgetting wave.
Because that's where
the diffusion picture
starts to become valid.